différente, à Québec, par
exemple, on craint un autre été
difficile, comme le dit Valérie
Gamache.
Privé des touristes étrangers,
les visiteurs se font rare
- Le château Frontenac est
l'hôtel le plus photographié du
monde. La rue du petit Champlain
est reconnue comme étant la rue
la plus remarquable du Canada.
Mais leurs charmes n'opèrent
plus de la même façon.
Privé des touristes étrangers,
les visiteurs se font rare
dans le Vieux-Québec.
La capitale a entregistré
une baisse d'achalandage
de plus de 60 % en 2020.
ROBERT MERCURE, directeur,
Office du tourisme de Québec
- C'est assez dramatique.
On commence à avoir des signes
qui sont un peu plus
encourageants pour cet été,
mais il faut travailler fort
pour bien remplir notre ville
cet été pour aider l'industrie.
- Sans ses festivals et son
effervesensce, la capitale
a peine à séduire le marché
québécois.
- C'est sûr que le marché est
plus limité, donc est-ce qu'on
va retourner aux normales
cette année? La réponse,
c'est non, mais on va être
nettement supérieur à qu'est-ce
qu'on a vécu l'an passé.
- L'été ne suffira pas
à combler le manque à gagner.
Les touristes québecois
ne laissent pas les mêmes
traces dans l'économie.
Lors de leur séjour,
les touristes étrangers
dépensent deux fois plus.
Et certaines clientèles
ne peuvent tout simplement pas
être au rendez-vous pour
une deuxième année d'affilée.
ANN CANTIN, Société du Centre
des congrès de Québec
- Normalement,
dans ce beau hall, c'est plein
parce que c'est la grosse saison
des congrès, ça commence
habituellement vers la mi-mars
jusqu'à la fin juin.
- En tout, 210 évenements
qui devaient avoir lieu
au Centre des congrès de Québec
ont été annulés, ce qui
représente 130 millions $
de moins en retombées
économiques pour les hôteliers
et les restaurants.
Dans cette industrie,
la reprise sera lente.
On ne prévoit pas de retour
à la normale avant 2024.
- La compétition va être vive,
mais on est quand même au moins
une vingtaine de centres
des congrès du type...
de celui-ci à travers le Canada
qui sont tous à la recherche
de la même clientèle parce que
le nombre d'associations
ne s'est pas multiplié
pendant la pandémie.
S'il y a de quoi, il y en a
moins, donc tout le monde,
on travaille sur le même marché.
- Et puis les quais du port de
Québec seront à nouveau déserts.
Les croisières sont interdites
au Canada jusqu'en février 2022.
- On se trouve actuellement
dans ce qu'on appelle
le terminal 30. L'automne 2021,
on aurait dû recevoir
les premiers passagers.
- Mais le port fait contre
mauvaise fortune bon coeur.
Faute de passagers, le nouveau
terminal de croisières
a été transformé en centre
de vaccination.
L'absence de croisièristes
prive l'industrie touristique de
700 millions $ et ce ne sera
simple de ramener
des bateaux à quai.
Les temps sont durs pour
les compagnies de croisières
et pour garder la tête hors
de l'eau, plusieurs ont dû
se départir de navires.
MARIO GIRARD, président-
directeur général Port de Québec
- Holland America a vendu
plusieurs bateaux dont ceux
qui venaient sur le St-Laurent.
Vous ne verrez plus le Veendam
puis le Maasdam qu'on est
habitué de voir à Québec
20 fois par année.
Nous, ce que l'on voit 2022,
c'est un redémarrage graduel.
On n'aura pas les niveaux qu'on
avait avant 3, 4 et même 5 ans
avant que ça redevienne ce que
c'était en 2019, ça va prendre
plus de temps.
- Dans ce contexte,
plusieurs établissements
touristiques remettent
leur survie entre les mains
des Québécois. En avril
dernière, l'Association
hôtelière de Québec a sondé
ses membres : 20 % d'entre eux
se disaient pouvoir tenir
le coup moins de 6 mois.
La moitié, moins d'un an.
- C'est pour ça que le message
est vraiment sortez, supportez,
dépensez parce que si on a
la moitié des joueurs à Québec,
ça risque d'être plate
dans le futur.
- Ici Valérie Gamache,